[Music]
[Applause]
just fanservice ever fuse it just kind
of it kind of feels a little bit like
home because I now can see everybody's
here when you're hosting and this feels
oddly familiar dude right I think you
just feel comfortable do you what about
your fan sir oh look I'm kind of little
nervous right now
very long time well you even got to read
the news so it's cool huh did you dust
it off all like hey old friend
no basically what everyone doesn't know
God okay okay yeah well so anyways
earlier we're kind of talking about some
fears that I was like telling people do
you know what my biggest fear is is
being misunderstood confessions corner
how have you been misunderstood that
made it terrifying oh no I just I don't
know I feel like a lot of the things
that my mom would complain about when
when we were all kids it's like always a
lot about money right in the finances
and how like you guys I won't be mean
because our poor you know and and like
she she my mom worked really hard on
saving up money right but I guess what
she wasn't receiving from my dad and
from anybody else in the family was
appreciation and so so like whenever she
completes oh yeah you know some so we
don't have this much money and then so
until we spend it on this and bah blah
blah and so like I remember I would like
to save the [ __ ] out of my money and
then I would try to like help my mom out
around the house right and because she
would always like kind of like passively
aggressive like make these comments be
like I'm here by myself working and no
one's here like washing these dishes bah
bah bah bah what gives you anxiety kind
of right and so when I do it I'm just
kind of like okay I did it mom you know
and then she's like oh but you know and
so what nobody else is helping me do
this and so I just feel like whenever I
tried to clearly communicate with my mom
like hey you know I'm here to help you
with whatever you need it just seemed
like that nothing was like really ever
satisfying her and I just feel like
hey you know like I'm doing this because
I'm doing it for you right because you
said you need the help and I want to
help you because I love you right
but she never really saw it that way she
was just like oh whatever you know like
well you're not doing yeah it's not what
I'm not doing and so I feel like it kind
of manifested into being like oh [ __ ]
like if I do this action like how would
that be read like if I do this like like
what would that the second-guess
yourself all the [ __ ] time which is
probably why like when I was around you
guys like initially I was so [ __ ]
nervous cuz of like oh [ __ ] if I if I go
to Joe and give him a napkin because he
spilled water himself does that make me
seem so desperate you know like it was
just it was just so insane the way that
I just twist these things up into my now
you know I don't give a [ __ ] either way
so fear of disappointment I mean you
feel like you try to help out your mom
but it always sounds like you're still
disappointing her so does that manifest
today where you have this fear of like
oh they don't understand me or what I'm
trying to do kind of because I think
when I try to talk to people to like so
you mean this I'm like no no no I I mean
like I I wanted to ask you this I don't
know verify my wording isn't like the
best well you think it's not the best
because of your mother's situation right
so yours you're assuming that your
bat-communicator because of that but
you're not necessarily a bad
communicator I feel like it forces it
when the other person who I'm trying to
talk to what if they're an idiot takes
it out of the different cuts I know or
they don't get some myself but also like
something simple right like a simple
miscommunication like hey Julia can you
do this and then you're like absolutely
and then I'm like hey I don't know if
this was done this way like you or
immediately go to mom mode where you're
like I [ __ ] up right right exactly I
feel like I I didn't get like when I was
growing up I felt like my mom didn't
like hear me not only did she not hear
me but she didn't really ask me
questions she never asked me like what
do you think about this or what is this
she would be like you feel like this
yeah and it like it [ __ ] it really
[ __ ] me up to the point that as an
adult I always feel the need to over
explain myself like I generally tend
like in business and stuff I kind of
like kind of know hey we should do XY
and Z but I'm afraid of coming off as
like overbearing or like rude or
something and so I end up
/ explain myself so that because my mom
always just misinterpreted what I was
feeling and I try to it's such a weird
thing it's hard to explain it it's hard
I mean so much talking to worry I mean
have you guys ever felt like you didn't
want somebody to think the wrong thing
of you so in order to make sure that
they do you like over-explaining over
again to the point that you're like oh
my God why did I explain something I
love ya I love dude because there's
there's a I think my pet peeve is people
taking bits and pieces of information
and drawing their own conclusions
starting to give me advice and I'm like
you don't even [ __ ] know listen and
then I start to panic and I start to
fight it whole I don't feel heard yeah
cuz it's like listen to everything you
son-of-a-bitch
and I think that stems from childhood
too because my parents didn't they were
stubborn and they always were like oh
you know I know everything you know the
best for you and then you start to
disrespect everybody around you that
don't listen because you think
everyone's stubborn and stupid and when
I was like 19 I did this [ __ ] that Bose
is talking about where I thought I knew
whatever the [ __ ] right so instead of
like I would get in arguments with
girlfriends and [ __ ] and instead of
trying to listen to what they were
trying to say I'm trying to fill in the
blanks already like what your mom did
that's probably what you're feeling what
you mean is or what you're prejudging
you and it's like and it's [ __ ] up but
it was an extension of how I felt like
communication worked yeah I was also in
like too emotionally abusive
relationships where they would Gaslight
me that's later we're like they I would
say like something would happen right
and I'd be like well I didn't like that
you did this like something shady you
know like I found this shady thing and
you did this and they'd be like that
didn't happen or they'd be like that
time we're easy
yeah and that's crazy why would you
think that oh you're probably thinking
that because in your child yep and I'm
like no this [ __ ] happens they can't
handle the blame so they cast it on you
okay I found you texting with this girl
and they're like why wait why are you
going to my phone
and then I was in this business
relationship where my manager he was
super manipulative and he ended up week
ended up suing me but he was threatened
to sue me for years and that's how he
got me under his control and then he
ended up actually suing me for like made
up think you had a manager that
threatened to sue you and you stayed
under no I couldn't I couldn't get out I
had legal people looking at these
contracts knew it was very almost
illegal the contract that he had me sign
and it was for five years and so he
would constantly hold over my head that
a piece sued me that I wouldn't be able
to pay for and I'd be broke for the rest
of my life so he I was too terrified and
I would just do whatever he wanted and
he would manipulate the [ __ ] out of
people and like then and then I would
run over that and then and then he would
yeah so he would he would I would tell
him the truth always because I was so
scared of him ever thinking that I was
doing something to undermine him because
I was terrified of him and he would be
like what's your game here what's your
what's your real agenda and I'm like I'm
telling you the truth like this is
actually like what it is and he's like
yeah but what are you really doing and
then once I that would piss me off that
would make me so having no confidence in
being trapped imagine like like just you
like dealing with a manager like that
where you tell them exactly like your
tape they know you're scared of them you
tell them ok X Y & Z thinkin like you a
hundred percent honest they're like but
come on yeah like that what do you what
are you doing here what kind of like put
him on speakerphone because I was
curling my hair because I was wanting to
go out to a show right after and he was
he takes for at like two our phone calls
five times a day and and so I put him on
speakerphone he's like why am I on
speakerphone why'd you put me on
speakerphone I hear I hear I feel like
I'm on speakerphone went out like you
are I'm curling my hair he's like I
gotta go
and so paranoid as [ __ ] cuz all the
things that he does to people like
having things recorded and over like I
have his lawyer listening and like all
the stuff he thinks that people are
doing that to him
so he projects all of the manipulation
tactics tactics that he does are [ __ ]
I'm oh yeah and he yeah he tried to kiss
me a few times to my countersuit sexual
harassment and
all kinds of our stuff and it was you
want it was pretty crazy no I can't
really talk about it right now but but
that's all public so you could look all
that up but but yeah so he would yeah he
would do that kind of stuff and so
forever like I would second-guess myself
like if I was allowed to say something
or if he would send emails being like
you did this to me and I'm gonna hold
this against you and you if you'd leave
a paper trail and he would say things
that he did to me and say that I did
them to him and he'd put it in paper and
have his lawyer copied on it and I I
just didn't it was the weirdest
experience I've ever gone through and
the most traumatizing experience and now
I'm so scared of being misunderstood but
I'm like no but I swear guys this is I'm
just telling you like it is all the time
so you never have to think that I might
be lying to you dude that's it and it's
so funny that every single one of us
we're like actually yeah so first of all
you're not alone Thanks like I think do
you guys you guys said you felt
similarly do you feel like it stems from
parents off - it depends on who because
if it's people I really care about and I
and I and for me I can separate how I
feel based off of relationship so if
it's if it's like someone I want a
future like just friendship relationship
or I care about your feelings then I
want you to know the real me if the
internet doesn't understand about ya or
somebody I encounter I don't give a [ __ ]
about them I mean that that's completely
you know to me I got a gauge and my
relationship based and my feelings I got
to withhold it depending on how
important someone is so yeah for me
that's how I am but there's a there's a
guest list of people into your heart you
know I'm saying yeah and there's layers
right cuz there's some relationships
where you're like you're unstable I like
you as a person but I gotta keep you
right here and that's not being Shady
that's just you got to watch your heart
right cuz you're like you don't really
know yourself that much yet you make a
lot of impulsive moves I do like you but
I think you got a lot of growth right
you don't let everybody in that's the
problem a lot of people go I like you
you're my friend I'm gonna let you in
everyone comes in well a lot of people
go like oh I wonder your fiction I want
your affection one your affection one
your fictional cuz it's a validation the
biggest mistake you can make in life
because I think a lot of people want to
be liked that's that's a normal human
thing
via celebrity because it won't be liked
and I think that's because we seek out
our value and validation through you
know a lot of people liking us which I
don't give a [ __ ] about what a loser
thinks I don't care about winning the
hearts of this person I don't know you I
don't know it's like why why do you work
so hard on strangers when you have
people that you should be spending that
hard and time with exact yeah absolutely
I have like a similar experience in
college I felt like I remember halfway
through college I had the revelation I'm
like I'm not gonna see half of these
people not even have way more that most
of these people five years from now
whatever like it doesn't I don't care
what kind of like misinformation is out
there about me in this circle or that
circle whatever cuz I'm never gonna see
them again and they're not gonna affect
my life in any kind of way because it
takes a lot of energy to convince them
and help them realize and sometimes it's
wasted because that's a hard thing to
come to come to a conclusion of like
that's tough yeah it's really good
especially being in college that's
really smart
cuz that's pretty early yeah cuz most
people in college they're looking so
much for validation and they want to be
liked by everyone so for you to be like
actually [ __ ] all them that's true
because in high school reputation is
everything yeah exactly and I would just
remember like in high school whenever I
would just talk to guys right or just
acquaintances of mine that like you know
we just passed by in class whatnot and I
guess like other girls to see me like
talk to these guys and like they'll say
[ __ ] behind my back and I'm like what
the [ __ ] that I do I literally wishes
your [ __ ] the producer how are you you
know and he was like oh I'm fine how are
you like cool see you later
you know I know like that's literally
the conversation I'm like we're in that
in between did I come off as like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you know so like to
me I'm just like I'm doing something
wrong for people to say that shit's me
so I think to me that's why I'm like
Fogg dude I want to be able to like
clearly communicate with people unless
what it's not it has nothing to do with
you yeah as I grew older I realize that
stems from I'm trying to understand what
you're saying Julia but you just come
off as a [ __ ] [ __ ]
see you know what if it's gonna be like
that then fine I'm about yelling at my
husband
Jesus Julie good why are you gotta sign
the [ __ ] out of me dude
gas side it means gonna call your
country I love you guys
[Music]
[Music]